so one of the things that happens when
we grow older with our nodding
resignation into nothingness is that we
enter a kind of consciousness known as
the bin there's and done vats of the
adult mind right it's that notion when
nothing excites or overwhelms any more
because you've seen it all before
and what a tragedy this is right I mean
come on I mean we all remember nostalgic
intensity of experiencing something for
the first time seeing the world through
the eyes of a child wonderstruck
entranced by all right succumbing to
astonishment giving in to astonishment
mouth gaped wide I mean damn to see
something for the first time but then
what happens then you assimilate you
model it in your brain stored in your
library have been theirs
done that and you no longer engage
rights and saw really with stimuli it's
called tonic adaptation familiarity
breeds boredom it's so depressing right
and so what do we do well I think this
is where mindful self inquiry comes in
this is where meditation this is where
breathing exercises and yoga comes in
this is where boarding a craft it flies
you across the world can be therapeutic
like injecting you with a little bit of
life by stimulating you and jet lagging
you and placing you in an entirely
different wallpaper of the mind it's
what it's why travel revitalizes it's
why people self-medicate sometimes
tweaking our perception sometimes that
marijuana joint can be the magnifying
lens or the pane of glass that doesn't
distort reality but confers on phenomena
a certain feeling of distances they
perhaps that's why a museum hangs an
ordinary item and puts it on the wall d
contextualizes it and brings our
attention back to it right we get to
enter the archetypical space where these
specific stands in for all of its kind
stands in for the universal right we
like to enter a modality of
consciousness known as plato's realm of
ideas I mean that's where you live in
the present
that's when anxiety about the future and
melancholy for the past get drowned out
by the ever-present rapture of the now
and we are free and in that moment we
are Adam and Eve in the Garden of Eden
before eating from the tree of knowledge
knowing no death knowing only now and
the bliss of now only we could get back
there I support whatever works
you